all right we need your help my help we
need as a as a as a society
to come together to figure out
who
left the pipe bombs in washington dc
um on the eve of the january 6th trump
riots the fbi has now released
significant information and video
but they don't know who the person in
the video is so we're going to go
through the the different information a
few days ago fbi in washington dc
saying
the fbi's washington field office has
released new information and video
regarding the suspect who placed pipe
bombs in the capitol hill neighborhood
of dc in january and is seeking tips
from the public identifying the
perpetrator of this attempted attack
remains a priority
okay the new information includes a
virtual map highlighting the route or
route that the suspect walked while
placing the two bombs on january 5th
between 7 30 and 8 30 p.m that's the
night before the riots at the capitol
one device was in an alley behind the
rnc headquarters uh on first street the
other was next to a parched bent park
bench near the dnc headquarters
on uh
south south capitol street
new video footage shows the pipe bomb
suspect sitting on a bench near the dnc
where the suspect later placed the pipe
bomb from this vantage point a full
front view of the suspect can be
observed they don't appear to know who
this is yet
the video which you can review
um is quite detailed and it starts with
actually showing the locations on a map
and the route that was believed to be
taken there are multiple videos as we're
showing our television audience where
you see the individual in a gray what
looks like a gray hoodie walking by
with a bag in which presumably they have
the pipe bombs this is a recreation of
the route using all sorts of uh of of
cameras that are there this is a video
that's been much uh promoted where the
individual does not look like a
particularly tall individual
is sort of what i would call is looking
casual as they have this bag presumably
with a pipe bomb
and you see them
stop a number of times and look around
put the backpack down
um i believe in this video someone
actually walks by and they sort of play
cool
looks like they're maybe on their phone
here they are wearing a mask and of
course that
may be more for making it difficult to
identify them than it is uh
because they want to stop the spread
let's put it that way an individual
walked by with their dog and the suspect
in question just kind of stood around
and then after that person walked by
they kind of go back over to the
backpack
pick it up
and then presumably keep moving they are
believed to have taken kind of a winding
route again maybe trying to
throw off surveillance in some sense
then sitting down on a park bench with
the very same backpack now there's a
couple things i want to mention that
have been speculated about and again the
the most important thing here before i
do any speculation
is
there is no way in hell
that there are no leads out there
they're they're simply
you know whether it's people that know
the individual and suspect it might be
someone they know
there's probably some of those although
maybe not
um other people who observed
suspicious behavior
maybe somebody who can say i think that
someone might have been here buying some
of the stuff you might need for the pipe
bombs the odds that no one knows
anything are very low so if you know
anything
get in touch with the fbi we're now
watching the suspect getting up from
that bench and continuing to walk with
the backpack
a 1 800 call fbi 1 800 call fbi one
eight hundred call fbi you can also
submit your tips online at
tips.fbi.gov
tips can remain anonymous if you would
like
okay
um
check out the video for yourselves now
now to the speculation and i this is
i i'm sort of doing this to get more
people watching the video and even if
you disagree with any of the
speculations that have floated around
maybe you will notice something about
the video that is useful
there are images where the way the
hoodie looks on the individual's head
who we're now seeing walk around
uh near some trash cans in a back alley
it looks like they may have sort of long
hair that's in either a ponytail or a
bun
that's been
stuffed in the hoodie because the the
behind in the neck area the hoodie looks
very bulky so that's one
speculation it may be totally wrong this
may be someone with short hair
this has led to some speculation that
this might be a woman now the fbi has
not said and overwhelmingly people who
do these things are male but i think
just as a general thing
until we really know anything we should
just keep an open mind about everything
now i don't know if i want to say
well where is that coming from i
apologize um
this this again just continues to be
idle speculation a friend of mine and a
bunch of people on twitter are saying
hey look if that that it looks like sort
of a short person maybe hiding a
ponytail could that be marjorie taylor
green and of course there's absolutely
no evidence for that but it is funny
that a friend of mine texted me about it
and then i started searching around and
a bunch of people are actually saying
this could be male could be female could
be young could be old we just we just
don't know
and my belief is someone must know
something
and if that's you
please contact the fbi 1-800 call fbi
tips.fbi.gov this could be anybody any
any profile whatsoever is the important
thing